the new trailer for spider-man no way
home offers fans their best look yet at
the return of alfred molina to the role
of the classic spider-man villain dr
octopus the mad scientist and his famous
four metal arms do battle with
spider-man on an elevated highway
tossing cars and construction material
as the young hero attempts to evade them
but just as he appears to get the better
of his nemesis it seems he's caught off
guard when he sees peter parker's face
acknowledging that the teenager before
him doesn't look like the peter he knows
peter for his part is surprised by
something else about the good doctor
peter asks in the next sequence one
where doctor octopus appears to be held
in a cell somewhere underground i'm
sorry what was your name again dr otto
octavius the villain answers because he
sure didn't earn those phds to be called
mr octavius but peter parker the same
guy who once said oh we're using our
made up names to dr strange finds this
hard to believe he and his friends mj
and ned very much don't buy the moniker
octavius gives them and in retaliation
they hit the doctor with every super
villain's worst fear teenagers laughing
at them peter asks wait no seriously
what's your actual name highly amusing
as the exchange is it has also left fans
with a big question does this imply that
the marvel cinematic universe doesn't
have its own auto octavius the mcu
disney plus show loki establishes the
idea that every mcu timeline has a
variant of every character even though
there may be some differences between
them as such fans are wondering where
the doctor octavius of the mcu is a
reddit user said referring to the
baseline earth 616 universe from the
comics so safe to say a 616 version of
auto does not exist in this universe
otherwise the name would be familiar
even if peter does not personally know
him after all in the sam raimi's
spider-man films corner of the
multiverse octavius is a major
scientific figure working on a
breakthrough in nuclear fusion and peter
parker is honored to have a chance to
meet him before the whole turning evil
thing happens if he's anywhere close to
that level of prominence in this
universe wouldn't a trio of geeky
students at the midtown school of
science and technology have at least
heard his name before instead of
thinking it's a joke others disagreed as
another reddit user chimed in saying i
don't know this peter's still in high
school i don't think it's out of line
for him to be unfamiliar with even
well-respected academics other fans
chimed in with other possibilities for
instance it was suggested that the mcu's
octavius could be olivia the female
version of the character voiced by
catherine hahn in spider-man into the
spider-verse but if that were the case
presumably the same last name wouldn't
crack up peter and his friends so much
one redditor suggested or maybe that was
the reason that peter and gang were
laughing because there's already an auto
octavius in the mcu so they probably
thought raymie's auto is a lunatic
imposter of course spider-man no way
home seems to be the most mysterious
corner of the mcu yet so there are
countless other possibilities as well
like the mcu version of peter parker
auto octavius could very well simply be
younger perhaps even a college student
who has yet to make a name for himself
he could even be something akin to
alligator loki happily bobbing about in
a florida swamp with four mechanical
arms lazily floating behind him the fun
thing about the marvel cinematic
universe is that any of these theories
might or might not potentially come true
at some point down the line the idea of
a radically different otto or olivia
octavius running around in the mcu main
timeline is an intriguing one especially
if there are more movie plans for the
character after all alfred molina is a
wonderful actor but he also debuted in
the role in 2004 so a recast may be in
the cards at some point in the coming
years it's not just doc ock either since
the mcu is now opening the door for so
many classic spider-man villains
portrayed by their classic actors no
less fans will no doubt have a field
date debating whether the other villains
exist in the mcu and if so in what
capacity has this version of peter never
heard of the famous ceo norman osborne
if not he's in for a pretty rude
introduction presumably audiences will
find out all these things and more when
spider-man no way home premieres on
december 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you